[Music]
my name is hisham azuz the founder of
recruitment mentors we recently hosted
our face-to-face live podcast event in
london we were joined by the amazing
tony phoenix coles from digital gurus
and chris shared from sr2 recruitment
who on the night were nothing short of
honest and authentic we came together to
discuss what have we learned in the last
18 months it was amazing to see so many
recruit professionals in one room
face-to-face sharing ideas perspectives
mistakes insights and it was a great
evening
take a look
[Music]
over this past year in lockdown i've
been speaking with people through
linkedin
video chat facetime putting i guess an
actual human interaction to it's been
fantastic
favorite part about the event is
definitely the guest speakers tony and
chris chris talked a lot about his
charity work you don't hear a lot about
who was in that field and that was
brilliant
i thought it's great it's the first
paneling i've done slightly nervous but
it was just quite chilled relaxed by
pretty open forum it was not like a
corporate stuffy boring and some really
good questions some challenging
questions but we had to actually think
club i think the audience actually
honest and open as opposed to just
saying what you wanted to hear kind of
things
people should definitely consider coming
to the next event especially if you're
new like me i'm three months in and i
already feel a lot more informed i'm
excited to go back to work the audience
their questions are brilliant it's a
really good environment survive i guess
interact with other people why would you
come
you